the still suit it's like heavy duty
bringing the epic film dune to life took
thousands of unique costumes extensive
facial prosthetics and 80 hours in a
makeup chair for one actor they have
ideas but you always discuss it yeah you
have to wear it
stellan skarsgard may not have
interacted much with many of his fellow
actors in dune but he got to know the
makeup and prosthetics team very well
since he spent such a significant amount
of time in the chair about 80 hours to
be exact that it's physically hard
mentally i can't do it because it's fun
watching them work every session was
around seven hours long as that's the
time it took five different artists to
bring the full transformation of baron
vladimir harkinan to life the facial
prosthetics skarsgard had to wear to
create the illusion of this
larger-than-life character were heavy
and no doubt with the addition of all
the filming lighting very hot making for
a not so ideal experience when
performing but luckily the actor pushed
through the fact that the prosthetics
were on and covered with extra makeup
and special effects to highlight details
on his face for so long meant there
wasn't a ton of opportunity for his skin
to breathe as well but i had seven hours
in makeup every day
because i had to be really fat
much of the body of the baron was
attached to a suspender type rig for
skarsgard to wear and float around with
the struggle to do so in an honest way
was tricky as it was very easy to slip
into a caricature carrying such
substantial gear and costumes many
artists from sweden were involved in the
building of the enormous suit that was
used it took a few people to build it
and help skarsgard actually get into it
the harness on and then you have the fat
skin on we can only imagine how much
relief he felt when he got to
de-transform and rid himself of all the
weight of his character
literally
it's a very complicated process dune may
be just the first part of a two movie
saga but the team didn't hold back on
anything at all especially not when it
came to building costumes and looks in
total approximately one 000 different
looks were created for the movie while
the team who built all these outfits and
fitted the actors for them was huge just
two costume designers minds brought the
vast range of looks to fruition but it
was a big undertaking among the thousand
looks were 200 costumes that had to be
built and putting together some of these
specialty costumes was extremely complex
taking a ton of detail and skill to
arrive at these stunning results
extensive time was spent researching
finding inspiration from varied and
sometimes surprising sources including
mythology medieval nuns david lean films
and perhaps most significantly the
colors of the landscape in jordan i mean
the costumes were gorgeous the way they
fit everyone filming in remote areas in
the literal desert in regions around abu
dhabi made it very easy for the
performers to go method since the heat
was nearly as unbearably intense as it
is in the story timothy chalamet claimed
at some points in the middle of the
night it was around a hundred degrees
making the still suit he wore on set
beyond uncomfortable while these
specially designed suits are meant to be
ideal for the desert and the story the
actual outfits worn include thick rubber
making filming in 120 degree weather
agony the confidence to be able to do it
came you know
let's say one percent for me 99 from
denise it wasn't easy conditions to work
in but they definitely helped immersing
chalamet and his fellow actors into the
story
even if it was a pretty sweaty one in
the end
that i had no clue what he was doing but
that i had some clue what he was doing
too and that really excited me when
making the film the team knew from the
start that gurney's signature scar from
the book was going to be important to do
justice to and create well on screen
it's a very simple detail but this type
of prosthetic can be difficult to
achieve realistically for the camera
especially because we see it pretty up
close started off from less is more the
makeup and prosthetic artists took their
time and began very small slowly
building up the look of the scar and
managed to really sell the idea in the
end the theme and the direction was so
powerful to me the still suits were an
arduous experience for both the
designers and the performers who wore
them
somehow the designers made the suits so
they included all the tubing gauges and
regulators that they would need to work
properly while also making sure to
consider style and how they would look
on screen
to make their work even more impressive
a mold of each actor who had to wear one
was made so the suits could be
specifically fitted for them
these outfits were far from light so
while they were exciting to wear they
were also very heavy and very warm it
feels like a big honor and a big
big challenge to take it on you know of
all the looks styling the appearance of
the harkonnens took the most work their
style was inspired by insects with
outfits that carry the look of scales
and ant like masks and for actor david
dust maltian they're some of the coolest
things i've ever worn in a film the
makeup and techniques used to bring the
antagonists of dune to life included
many steps from their eerily smooth
looks to the bug-inspired outfits and
armors
the actors had to sit through a long
makeup process which included their
eyebrows being blocked off prosthetics
bulb caps and making sure the texture of
their faces was extremely smooth
a lot of detail and nitpicking is needed
to achieve such a look so the makeup
artists had to give their full attention
to the creations leaving them totally
exhausted on their already extremely
long filming days the baron wouldn't be
the baron without his large costumes
that he moves around in the pieces
themselves had to be substantial while
looking sharp proving to be a challenge
to build and wear skarsgard was already
weighed down by countless elements but
he managed to use the outfit to his
advantage and fully embodied the baron
stealing was quite frightening as the
baron fantastic performance it was all
worth it especially since the actor was
actually able to see a different light
of his character further informing his
performance
it may not have been the most complex or
eye-popping but it sure was effective
and moving this plane-faced simple look
was actress rebecca ferguson's favorite
in the whole film she had makeup on but
designed to look kind of raw and sort of
translucent at the same time the
combination of which took a lot of time
to complete properly this visual
combined with her hair being let loose
and pajamas on the beach made for a
pretty special experience donald moet
had plenty of places he could seek
inspiration from but the designer wanted
to go into his work with a clean slate
and opted not to watch the david lynch
version of dune
but avoiding influence turned out to be
trickier than he'd anticipated as one of
the makeup artists from that very
adaptation reached out to him mo wasn't
working alone to bring a fresh and
unique design to the screen though i
mean
i have some phenomenal people working i
mean
you know
great people
since there were multiple people
creating the world together the team
needed to find a way to work effectively
making sure everyone got to see each
other's designs
cue photoshop collaboration magic
they wound up editing images together so
they could see what each had dreamed up
and used the best of all their work
every cast member existed in a document
created by the designers that saw their
styles and looks changed throughout the
development and creation process
the costumes makeup and prosthetics as
painful and arduous of an experience as
they might have been definitely rose to
the occasion of this epic film
how would you feel having to wear a
still suit in such extreme heat